Snowflakes are one
of mother nature's
most exquisite creations--
fragile snow crystals
that dazzle us in an array
of shapes and sizes.
But there's a lot more to
these intricate ice formations
than meets the eye.
Turns out that by
looking a lot closer,
snowflakes may also
help us save lives.
Here's correspondent Francesca
Fiorentini's fascinating look
at the secrets of snowflakes.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI: Beautiful
and delicate, but also deadly.
MAN: It came out of nowhere.
When you're caught in an
avalanche, it's terrifying.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI:
Most avalanche deaths
are caused by suffocating
under deep drifts
or from the blunt
force trauma inflicted
by the onrush of snow.
In fact, these giant
masses of snowflakes
can reach speeds of 80 miles per
hour within about five seconds.
MAN: Imagine being
in a car crash,
and you're trying to just
hopefully save yourself.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI: And
time runs against you.
After an hour has
passed, only one
in three of those hit by an
avalanche are found alive.
The threat is so
real that 150 people
get killed by these juggernauts
around the world every year.
In just a two-week span
in February, 2018, seven
people died from avalanches in
one area of Washington state.
Three of them lost their
lives on mountain passes
just like this one.
REPORTER: Three people
have been killed
in two separate avalanches
over the weekend.
Rescuers found an adult
near Stampede Pass
in Kittitas County yesterday.
These deadly incidents
illustrate the extreme risk--
not just in the back
country, but even
on the heavily used trails.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI:
That's why I
came here to the shadow of Mt.
Rainier to meet the daredevils
that stop these deadly beasts
before they strike.
So what's strange is that
you all work for the Department
of Transportation.
When I think of the DOT, I
don't think of avalanches.
I think of a bus depot, or--
Right.
Yeah.
Because we have snowy mountain
passes and avalanche hazard,
we also have avalanche
specialists who are
highway avalanche forecasters.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI:
State Route 140 takes us
up the mountain on the Chinook
Byway, a 92-mile hotspot
for avalanches.
And this road turns out
to be one of the worst
places an avalanche can hit.
With 30,000 vehicles
a day, and midweek,
we have 7,000 to 10,000 semis--
so there's a tremendous
amount of people
moving across the highways,
but also a lot of goods.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI: We
finally make it to Chinook's
actual mountain pass.
The snowiest mountain
pass that WSDOT operates.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI: It's
here where we find clues
to the formation of avalanches.
We have today's snowfall.
And then we can look
at this upper layer.
That can pull off pretty easily.
It's sitting on this
nice, thin little crust.
It's very fragile.
Underneath that is
this really loose,
unconsolidated, wet snow.
Yes.
As we move down, it gets a
little more firm, and again,
wetted snow underneath there.
We can start to see
some additional layers.
So the fact that there are
different consistencies of snow
layers actually make the
conditions for an avalanche
more likely.
More likely, exactly.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI: It's not
long before John's team finds
a classic avalanche trigger--
a cornice, a mass of
hardened snow hanging
precariously above the road.
And you see the big
overhanging piece of snow?
That's the cornice
that we're looking at.
Your concern is that it's
going to fall on its own.
If it falls on its own, yeah.
We hope to remove the cornice
and make that area safe.
Meaning explode it away?
Exactly.
So the crew started setting
up explosives in that area.
Would you hold that, Andy?
Sure.
Thank you, sir.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI:
The demolition team
has a tough task.
They need to blow up the
cornice without rattling
the surrounding area and setting
off an uncontrolled slide.
This is going to be loud.
All right.
You ready for this?
I think so.
OK.
All right, guys.
3, 2, 1, fire.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI:
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
You can see the slide
coming down now.
There it goes.
Whoa!
That was crazy.
That went really fast.
Yeah, that looked good.
OK.
Copy that.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI: Their work
is crucial for people's safety
and for the economy.
But what if there
was a better way
to prevent avalanches than
hunting them down one by one?
Well, in order to
understand avalanches,
you first have to
understand snowflakes.
I'm here at Montana State
University's Subzero Lab, where
researchers are at the
forefront of discovering
the science behind snowflakes.
This 27,000-square-foot
facility is
one of the leading cold science
research centers in the world.
Yeah, OK.
Now I get it.
I know why it's a subzero lab.
OK.
How cold is it in
here right now?
Around minus 10 Celsius.
All the time?
All the time.
Over here in the center, can
actually see the crystals grow.
That is so cool.
So if you put
your glove behind--
May I take a snowflake?
Sure.
Wow.
It's beautiful.
That's totally doable.
Lab Director Dr. Ed Adams
says there's a lot more
to snowflakes than we think.
Snow is-- it's kind
of like a shape shifter.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI: Snowflakes
aren't frozen raindrops.
They form when water vapor in
clouds skips the liquid phase
and crystallizes
straight into a solid.
There are at least 35
types of snowflakes.
Some are shaped
like needles, others
are dotted with ice
granules, and some
are irregular crystals.
Even though all of them
fall at the same time,
when it comes to
forming avalanches,
the prettiest one of them all
can be the fastest to act out--
the stellar dendrites.
The little stellar
dendrites, those
little star-shaped crystals--
Those are the beautiful,
holiday card, star snowflakes.
Excactly.
Exactly.
After they hit the
ground, then they
go through this metamorphism.
They tend to change form.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI:
Most snowflakes generally
have six arms formed
by the accumulation
of water molecules--
two hydrogen atoms
and one oxygen atom.
But the stellar dendrites'
arms are particularly unstable.
They morph faster than other
snowflakes, which can create
a continuous hard layer
of snow that can stretch
across entire mountainsides.
But sometimes, the
snowflakes stay separate,
creating a weak, pillowy layer.
If another hard layer is
forged on top of this snowpack,
the millions of
snowflakes beneath them
have set the stage for one
of the most deadly forces
on Earth.
You've got a strong layer.
You've got a little weak layer.
Then we have a strong
layer on top of it.
That's your recipe
for the avalanche.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI: By
studying the mechanics
of a snowpack and analyzing
the snowflakes inside it,
Dr. Adams' team is trying to
improve avalanche prediction
in order to save human lives.
Ultimately, what could
your research lead to?
Could you imagine something
like a Google Maps of avalanches
in the next 15, 20 years?
Yeah, certainly.
We can get closer to that.
FRANCESCA FIORENTINI:
One day you might
be able to browse an
app that tells you
where the snowflakes
to avoid lie.
But until then,
avalanche hunters
are going to keep trudging
into the back country
to try and understand and
prevent the next disaster.
So the next time you see snow
falling from the sky, just
remember that these
tiny crystals are
beautiful, but also dangerous.